で 直接テーマに話に入りますが
あの 頼りになるものならないものというテーマで
大体仏教の話を聞くと
いろいろ何も頼りにならないというふうな感じの話
聞こえるかもしれません
今思い浮かんだのは この禅の言葉一つなんですね
禅ではよく言うんです
仏陀の道というのは不立文字だと
いわゆる言葉で語れないんだと
で 経義仏典という禅の言葉がございます
いわゆる経典とは違いますと
仏陀の教えはとと言って
テキストやら勉強に勉強などはもう嫌うという話は言ってますけど
でも結局たくさん文学作っているのは禅宗なんです
禅の世界なんですね いろんな文学やらいろんなものを使ったりするんです
ですから まあある面では言葉にはならないと
言葉は関係ないと言いながら
いっぱい言葉使ってるんですね
同じ特色は まあ初期仏教についても言えるんですからね
だから何も頼りにならない
何も頼りにならないと言いながら
結局いろいろ頼りになるものは説明しているんです
ですから いくらかこの否定的なところで喋りますけど
それは否定的ではなくて
ある何かを肯定しているんです
じゃあ まあそれは一応頭に置いておいて
で 頼りになるということにすると
まず我々に出てくるのは
やっぱりなんで頼りになるかっていうこと
それはいろいろ不安があるんだからなんですね
心配事があるんだからなんですね
で で 助けてくれと 頼みたくなるのは
やっぱり何か自分に何か大変なことある時なんですね
ですから もし人間には何も不安がなければ
何も危険がなければ 何も問題なければ
別に頼るっていうことはもう関係なくなっちゃうんですね
ですから 一般的に考えると
じゃあ我々には安心して生活できるかと
何のも不安 不安 人生にはないんですかと
危機っていうのは何一つもないかと
どうしようもない状態には全然陥ることは全くないんでしょうかと
というと 大体そうではないんですね
いろいろ問題が起きてくる
じゃあその時どうすればいいんですかと
何に頼ればよろしいかと
という答えの問題なんですね
ですから この頼りという言葉は
仏教でもいろんな言葉でたくさん
今日いろいろ経典調べたんだけど
あまりにもありすぎてありすぎて
どうしようもなくやめちゃったんです
みるみる所にあるんですね
あるんだけど この短い話でまとめられるものではなくて
あまりにも世界観膨大だから
まあやめた方が無難だと
一応言葉だけ いくつかの言葉だけありまして
この頼りということに
仏教では一般的に使っている言葉は
このサラナという言葉なんですね
サラナっていうのは この日本語で帰依という言葉に翻訳しているんですね
もう頼るという言葉よりも
それは純粋な仏教用語なんですね
サラナっていうのは でも一般的な意味はもう頼るという意味なんですね
だからブッダンサラナンガッチャーミダンマンサラナンガッチャーミという場合はもう頼るという意味なんですね
[沈黙]ですから 一番一般的な正しい仏教の言葉はサラーナという言葉なんですね
で だから頼る場合はね
いろいろ頼り方がありますけどね
もう完全に頼ると もう救ってくださいと
例えば人が病気になって手術しなくちゃいけない状態になったところで
まあ自分では手術できませんだからね
医者に完全に頼ってしまっちゃうんですね
どうせ麻酔なんかつけちゃったところで
もう何も自分でわかりませんだからね
ですから 他人のやりたい放題
で 手術している途中で全部ちゃんと説明してくださいと
私の意見聞いてやってくださいと
この頼りを半分にしちゃったら成り立たないんですね
例えば 完全麻酔かけなくちゃいけない時はね
じゃあだったら あなたにはローカルアネステティックというか
何といいますか この部分だけ麻酔かけて
じゃあ話をしましょうと言ったっても
それは手術次第にうまくいく場合もいかない場合もあります
そうやって完全に頼るということも世の中ではあります
だからサラーナっていうのは完全に頼ることかと
それちょっとわかりにくいんですけど
仏法僧のことをサラーナ帰依するんだから
そこはまあ人の勝手でね
完全に頼ったってもよろしいし
まあ自分の自由をありながら
まあそこそこ頼ったっても
それはもう人によりますからね
でも仏教のこのサラーナ
帰依の場合は この論理性は失ってはならないんですね
ちゃんと合理的に論理的に頼ると
そこは論理性失っても
もうどうでもいいんだから助けてくれということではないんですね
そこら辺は気をつけてほしいんですね
例えば仏法僧に完全に頼っちゃいますよと
仏教徒だからという場合は
だからといってこの論理性を失っちゃうとうまくはいくわけじゃない
いつでも合理的に論理的に物事を考えて頼った方がいいということはあります
そこでまたいろいろこの頼りに関わる言葉があります
経典の中を見ると まず書いている言葉
このターナという言葉
ターナっていうのは安全なところという意味で
まあいろんな危険な時
精神的な 物質的にいろんな危険は人間にある場合は
何かターナという安全なところがないんでしょうかという風な言葉が使ってあって
それからレーナという言葉もあるんですね
で レーナというのは隠れるところと私は書きましたけどね
それも一つの頼りのやり方なんですね
身を隠すと で ターナの場合は隠す必要ないんです
こちらは安全だよと 安全なところに行く
堂々と上代と 例えば熊は自分を追ってきたら
木を登って上にしてどうですかと
もう隠れるわけじゃないんですね
その場合は安全なところにいる
でもレーナという場合はやっぱり隠れちゃうんですね
放射能でもあっちこっちもう汚染しちゃうと隠れなくちゃいけないんですね
堂々と堂々と何かの安全な場所にいて
身を現して表していることはできません
ですから 頼るにもいろいろやり方があります
そこで 3番目 下にあるのはケイマという言葉なんですね
ケイマというのは 私はまあまあそこそこ安らぎという意味を書きましたけどね
それは何かほっとすることなんですね
心の問題なん 何か問題があって
その問題をなんとか乗り越えて
何か心の安らぎ ほっとする気持ち
そういう気持ちになることも
一つの人間に対して頼りなんですね
そこではっきりした頼りという日本語の言葉使えるのは
このパティッターという
言葉なんですね それは何て言いますか
高いところで仕事をすると
何かあの腰に何か 何て言いますか
命綱つけちゃうでしょ
それやるともう安心します
それは本当の頼りなんですね
ですから 私たちにも人生の中でそういう命綱のようにいろんなことをやっていると
まあ何かあったらすぐ助けてくれるというパティッターという
そういう頼りもあります
命綱のような頼り そこで次の言葉はニッサラナ
まあニッサラナは一応解放と書きましたけどね
だから解放という場合は
ニッサラナという場合は
我々はいろんな条件でいろんなことで悩んでいて
それでその条件やら悩んでいるものから解放しちゃう
そういうふうな頼り方
いわば例えばまあ悪いことをしたとわかっても
まあ一応許してあげますということがあったならば
それはニッサラナなんですね
解放なんですね ですから
日常生活の中でも そういういろんな種類の我々には安らぎを感じちゃうんですね
まあ例えば まあ自分の家に
まあ親戚の誰かがまあいきなり田舎から来て泊まったとする
それでまた向こうでも大変な楽に自由に生活していたんだから
もう東京の中で狭いところで
まあわがまま放題になったりすると
で こっちはこちら家に
もうこちらに住んでいる人にとっては
これちょっとした迷惑なんですね
だから親戚だからね もう帰れとも言えないし
もうこれすごく苦労を感じちゃうでしょ
そこでまあその人はまあ面倒くさいんだから
東京の生活は それは帰りますと
で 帰った時はなんとなく解放されますね
あの問題から だから問題から解放されることはニッサラナということなんです
それからアバヤという言葉がございまして
アバヤはこのまあコンピューターで調べたなかなか漢字が出てこなくて
一応こういう無畏と書きます
それ正しいかどうかわかりません
バヤっていうのは恐怖ということで
アっていうのはないということ
ですから恐怖がないという意味なんですね
おそらく仏教専門的な言葉では無畏と言うと思います
アバヤ で まあいろいろ何と言いますか
心配事が大体ありますね
怖いことが そういうことから
なんとかもう大丈夫だという気持ちになるならば
それはアバヤというような感じのタイプの頼りなんですね
例で言えば何でしょうかね
まあ例えば車を運転するのはちょっと危険なんですけど
一応保険かけておく そうすると何かあってももう大丈夫ということ
火事も怖いんだけど 一応保険かけておくと
まあそれでアバヤにはなれませんだけどね
まあ一応そんなような感じなんですね
まあ別に怖くはないんだと
いろいろセキュリティシステムに入ったりするでしょ？セコムとかいろいろありますからね
で あれはもうあっち頼ってるんですね
そのセキュリティシステムに
警備制度に なぜかというと怖いんですね
泥棒が入ったらどうしようかと
出るこの怖さをなくすために何かに頼る
それをアバヤと言うんですね
それからこの 三つの言葉がございます
ヴィモーチャナ パモーチャナ
ヴィモッカとかね 全部このお釈迦様の経典で出てくる言葉なんですね
それはほんの一部なんです
ヴィモーチャナ パモーチャナ
ヴィモッカ 全部まとめて同じ動詞から出てくるんですね
ムチという  MUCI のムチという動詞から出てくる言葉だから
まあ一つにまとめたんですけどね
これはまあ解脱するという意味なんですね
いわゆる脱出して自由になると
逃げろと そういうことで
危険から逃げた方がいいと
例えば まあ火山で爆発して
なんとか溶岩が流れてでも来るんだったらね
もう毒ガスでも出てくるんだったらどうしますかね
逃げるしか方法ないでしょうに
その場合は逃げる ある時は安全な場所を作ると
そうやってこのもう頼るんだという言葉は単純じゃないんです
我々にはいろんな形の危険
危機が迫ってくる その危機に応じた耐え方がなければいけないんですね
ですから そういういろいろ言葉使ってるんです
ですから 完全に頼るべきか
中途半端で頼るか まあ五分五分頼るかって
そういうのは一概に何と言いますか
一概にこれということは言いにくいんです
例えば 大きな手術の場合は外科に完全に頼らなくちゃいけないんです
完全に信頼して はい お願いしますと
それで自分にはもう自分の意思も何もなくなっちゃうんですね
もう麻酔かけられますからね
だからといって じゃあ
いかなる場合でも 人が病気になる
いかなる場合でも完全にお医者さんに頼れと言ったら
それはそうじゃないんですね
時々手術するかしないか
自分で判断しても構いません
そういう時もあります
あるいはその治療法は嫌ですよと言って断ることもやってもいい時もありますし
断れない時もあります
他の方法がない場合は
一番わかりやすいのはがんの場合なんですけど
じゃあがんになったら自分が手術受けるか受けないかと自分で判断したっても構いません
そこでいろいろ抗がん剤とかいろんな治療を受けるか受けないかと
その場合は自分は完璧に頼るんじゃなくて
自分の判断もする でもやっぱり大事にしなくちゃいけないなということになったら
じゃあ先生頼みますということにならなくちゃいけないんですね
それから危機によって危機から逃げるとかね
あるいは別に逃げることをしないで安全な場所にいるとか
それはもうターナなんですね
逃げることはレーナですからね
そのように私たちはこのこの頼るということは分析して理解しなくちゃいけないんですね
なんでこの宗教の世界でそういうことを喋るかというと
これから一般論に入りますけど
この バルブが消えちゃったら弁償しなくちゃいけない
で なんかこの宗教の世界で
この精神的にものすごくこの人をこの束縛して捕まるような
まあ傾向あるんですね
例えば神様を信じる宗教だったら
この完全に神に頼る 風にも言ってる人もいるし
それは完全ではなくて
まあこの世の中のことを自分に頼れと
もう心のことは神に頼れという風に二分化している
同じキリスト教の中でもいろいろありますけど
それで人々はこの頼るということは勉強していないんだからもう誰かに頼っちゃったら何だかんでもその人に頼ろうとする
それでいろいろトラブルが起きたりする
なんでトラブルを送りますかというと
この頼るというその機能を勉強していないんですね
最近できたトラブルなんですけど
あの人々にこの宗教の人が
まああなたは音楽家になりなさい
あなたは芸術家になりなさい
あなたはもうこういう仕事をしなさいとか
何か決めてくれるんですね
で そこでその人に完全に頼っちゃって一応殺されるんですね
実際に 一番最近のニュースでしょ
だからそちらで一般的な医学的な人が死んだと言っても
その宗教の世界では死んだと認めない
だからそうやって頼ることになってしまえば
もう無茶苦茶社会に迷惑なんですね
なぜ迷惑かというと どこまで頼ってどこまでで自分の責任を持つかという
この区別判断がなくなっちゃったんですね
別にそういう区別判断があったならば
その宗教は別にそんなに社会に悪いこと迷惑はならないんですね
だから宗教を語る人も信じる人も
あまりこの問題は明確にしてないんですね
俺に頼れと 俺がグルですよと言うだけで
で 頼ると言っちゃったんだから
まあ病気になっても治してくれるんだと
死んでも生き返してあげるんだということに
まあ仕事も私は選んであげるんだと
そうするともう何一つも人間には自由にできなくなっちゃうんで
それはうまくいかないんですね
ですから この完全たる万遍なくすべての側面から我々の人生を助けてくれる頼りがそちらにもないということなんで
分析しましょうと その方が私たちにはかなり軽く生きていられます
ですから 今日はもう別にあまり変な話をしないで
単純な話をしたいんですし
で ですから この 難しいことではなくて
我々は人 何かに頼るんだったら
ただ頼るということではなくて
頼るということを分析してみて
適当に頼ってみましょうと
そこでこの前鈴木さんにも質問して答えたんだけど
頼るといえばどういうこと？それについては経済ことこといろいろありますと
私はその通りだと思います
人間は経済活動に頼っていますね
だから収入は経済活動から出てくるんだから
仕事をしなくちゃいけないんだから
だから仕事に頼っています
それは決して悪いことではないんです
仕事に頼らなかったら死んじゃいますから
仕事をなければ 収入がなければ
じゃあそこで考えてみましょう
収入がなければ人が死ぬ
ですから 収入が経済活動が
活動自体が人の命を預かって守ってくれるかと
その逆計算で問題が変わっていっちゃうんですね
だから経済活動しなかったら
収入がなかったら人は生きていられません
それはマルなんです ですから
経済活動に収入に頼るべきなんです
そこで生きていられませんということは死ぬことだから
経済活動しなかったら人が死んじゃうんだということは
人は生きているということは
命は経済活動によって支えられているんだと計算すると
そこはバツなんです それは間違っているんです
だから世の中でその区別しないんですね
それでトラブル起きちゃうんですね
だから私はよく使う例は
この人間は死すべきもの
すべての人間は死すべきですという言葉と
それ逆に言えば死すべきものはすべてが人間ですと言っちゃったらおかしいでしょう
たまらないでしょう おかしくて
それはおかしいんです
だから AイコールBゆえにBイコールAではありません
方向性があるんです これは数学で頭が狂ってしまっちゃって
数学っていうのは実際しない観念的な世界だけなんです
頭の遊びだけなんですね
ですから 数学ではもしAイコールBであるならば B
イコールAもう当たり前
もう何言うんですかと
ぐらいのことなんですね
でも実際はそうではありません
ですから 世の中にある真理には方向性があるんだと
と理解してほしい ですから
経済活動 収入っていうのはどんな人間も頼るものなんです
だから もし宗教家が言うならば
経済活動に頼るなと それは嘘であって
経済活動なしに生活できないはずなんです
神様にお祈りすれば すべてのものは
何と言いますか 叶ってくれるんだと言ったら
これはもうインチキカルト宗教なんですね
そういう傾向はあるんです
それは論理性ないんだからなんです
聖書でもほんのちょっと読んでみると
最初のところではもうすべてもう揃ってあげてるんだと
人間に必要なものは だから何必要ないんだと
ある文章でこうあるんですね
鳥なんかとかね 動物とか
明日何食うか悩んでるんですかと
なんでないでしょうということを人間に言うんです
だからあんたは心配するなと
何でも用意して揃っているんだよということを言いたがってるんですけど
私が言いたいのは それはちょっと危険ではないかと
ですから 宗教の世界にしたっても
経済やら収入っていうのは人間の頼りになるものですよっていうことは否定できない事実なんです
でもそこで仏教は それでも仏教はケチをつけてるんです
どこにケチをつけてるんですかというと
この左から右へ行けば論理は正しいんだけど
右から左へ行っちゃうと全く間違っているんですね
そこを気をつけて勉強しなさいと
[終始背景音楽]ですから
経済活動に仕事に頼ることは
まあそれはそれで構いませんだけど
そこは条件付きなんですね
完全に何だかんでもそこに頼るわけではありません
ですから そこを割り切って
これは収入を得ることだけですと
だから自分の生活を成り立たせ
自分と自分の家族の生活を成り立たせるために
その収入を得る だからそこら辺でちゃんとお互いに頼りあって
信頼し合ってちゃんとやればいいんです
でも 会社の社長にあんたは子供一人しか作ってはいけませんという権利はありません
あんたは結婚したらもう仕事に精出せませんから
結婚するなという権利はないんです
もし会社の方が仕事の方がそこまで手を伸ばすんだったら
これはちょっと やりすぎということは言えるんですね
そこで家族が危機になっているにも関わらず
旦那が仕事に行くんだったら
これはちょっとおかしいんですね
そういう風にする人もいるんですね
仕事は命だと そこは間違っていて
仕事は命ではないんです
そうやって耐えるのはいいんだけど
このどこまでかと 同じことを医学の世界についても言えるでしょうに
お医者さんと医学の分野がなければ人は死んじゃうでしょうに
風邪引いただけでも死ぬでしょうに
それだったらわからないしね
ほんのちょっとの病気でも
人がちゃんと手当てしないと死んでしまうっちゃうんですね
だから医者っていうのは
何やっても人の命を守っているんですね
ということは 間違って論理的に考えちゃうと
やっぱり医者は人の命を守っているんだと
それで ですから私たちは生きているのは医者のおかげですよと言うとおかしいでしょうね
全然生きているのはお医者さんのおかげではないんです
でも お医者さんがいなかったら死んじゃうんです
そうやって あの頼るっていうものはどういうものかというと
我々は服に頼っているし
それで寒さからなんとか身を守っているし
建物にも頼っているし
だから安全に生活できているし
それからもう色々交通機関に頼っているし
それで人生は便利になっているし
いろんなものにも頼っているものっていうのは
もう限りなくあります
そこら辺で この明確にこの論理性
この方向性というものを考えてほしいんですね
例えば お金に頼るというと
ことはね いかに世の中狂っているかというと
お金はすべてだと お金さえあればもう誰も文句言いませんと
何でもお金で解決できますと
お金で解決できないものは何一つもないんだとか
そんなもうまるっきり屁理屈であって
何の論理もないんですね
で 彼らはこのいつでも逆方向で論理を使っているんです
使うべき方向ではなくて
すべての人間は死すべきですよという方法ではなくて
死すべきものはすべてが人間ですよという方向で論理を作っているんですね
ですから 手段はどうであろうが
金さえあればもう大丈夫だというところまで行ってしまっちゃうんですね
そこで世界が狂っているだけのことで
別にお金は悪だとかね
言ってるわけじゃないんです
だからこの宗教の言葉を無茶苦茶に使って
お金は悪だから あなたの財産
全部この宗教団体に寄付しなさいと
言ったら じゃあまあ寄付しますよと
それで私はどうやって生きてます？あんたもそちらに生活すればどうですかねって
もうなんとかくれるものを食べて
もう奴隷みたいに働いて
なんかカルト宗教団体に入って苦しい生活して
結局殺されちゃうんでしょうね
日本でもヨーロッパでもそういうカルトグループというのは結構あるんですね
アメリカにもいくつかいろんなところであって
消えてまた現れたりする
終わりがないんですね
そこでみんな自分の財産
収入はそちらに入れちゃって
そうすると 1円も持ってないんだから
そこでそのグループの中に入ってくれるもの何か食べて生活する
これ 1週間ね  1週間ただでくれるんだけど
それから宗教団体は厳しいんですね
働かせちゃうんですね
でも収入はない 働いても給料はなし
奴隷にしちゃうでしょうに
逃げようと思ったら捕まっちゃうでしょうに
あるいは殺しちゃうでしょうに
なんでそういうことこの世の中で現れるかというと
人間は決してインテリじゃないんだから
論理的じゃないんだからなんですね
だから本当にお金は悪である場合もあります
お金は悪になる場合はあります
それもみんな知ってるんだから
お金がたくさん貯まっちゃうと
すごく威張りたくなる
見栄を張りたくなる それで余計ないろんなことをしたり
社会に迷惑をかけて 人間に迷惑をかけたりして
いろんな酷いことをする可能性はあります
で 戦争にしたって それはほとんどお金が絡んでいるんだから
なんで世の中で戦争終わらないかというと
これ儲かっちゃうんですね
人を殺すと そこでお金持ってる人々は
自分の嫌な人々はもう消せと
この殺し屋にお金を払ったりするでしょ
そんなのいくらでもありますからね
この地球上では ですから
もう確かにお金が悪になる場合もあります
それは一つの例 もう一つあります
自分がたくさんのお金を持っている
でも別に悪いことはしようとはしない
個人的にお金たくさん持っていて
そうするとまた精神的に不安になっちゃうんですね
お金がなくなったらどうするんですかと
誰かに盗られたらどうするんですかと
だから 日本風に言えば
日本では銀行にお金を納めておいても盗られやすいでしょう
誰かに判子を盗まれたら
もうそれで終わっちゃいますから
全然信頼性ないんですね
その点では 外国では無理ですからね
本人が行ってサインしなくちゃね
自分の国ではそれは難しいんです
ちゃんと個人的にそのお客さんを知らないと
だいたい大金は出してくれない
それであまり行かない場合は
もう顔写真までコンピューターにサインと顔写真まで入ってるんです
この間 私は銀行に行って
昔の銀行口座だからね
私は英語でサインしたが
国の言葉でサインしてさっぱりわかりませんと
でもお金出してくれと言ったんですね
言ったら ああそうですね
じゃあ調べましょうと言って
とにかくとりあえず私は 2つサインしますよと
2つサインして それでちょっと見たら
ドーンと大きな画面で
私の昔の顔と写真と顔写真とサインと
もう全部出ているんですね
だからもう本人かどうか何のこともなく
サインたとえ間違っても顔がありますからね
顔を見たらこの人だと分かりますからね
ですから この判子と通帳盗まれただけで
ちょっとお金なくなった
ちょっと危険すぎですけどね
とにかくそういうこともないわけないんですね
だから 盗られたらどうしようかと
盗まれたらどうしようかと
そういうふうに精神的に心配が出てくる
あるいは自分の息子なんですけど
もう親孝行しないで お嫁さんの言うことばっかり聞いて
家を出て もう見ようともしないと
そうすると自分が死んじゃったら
自分の財産がそちらに行くでしょうに
あげたくないと あげたっても
あの嫌なお嫁さんにお金がいくんだ
財産行くんだからとかね
そういうふうなことですっごく悩んでる人々
私も知ってる人々がいるんです
死ねないんだと なぜかというと
この財産がお嫁さんのところに行っちゃいますからと
いくら息子に行ったとしても
結局お嫁さんのものになるんだと
と恨んだり 憎んだりしている
だから そういう点で見ると
やっぱりお金はやっぱり悪になってるんですね
本人にとっては 精神的にすごい苦しみを作ったりする
だから分かりやすいことは捨てなさいと
全ての財産をね でもそんなことを
そういう言葉がね 悪用してはいけないんですよ
非論理的な人々に 無知な人々に
世の中でよくそれは起こっている
起きているんです この 21世紀の世界で
宗教家が言っていた言葉が全て悪用されているんですね
例えば 大体キリスト教にしたって
仏教にしたってもね 寄付しなさいと
布施しなさいよと 人を助けなさいよと
堂々と言っているんです
お金なんか財産なんかろくなことにならないんだと
あの聖書を見てもね 金持ちが天国に行くということは
針の穴からラクダが通るぐらいのもんだと
と言っているんでしょうし
それは決して間違っている言葉じゃないんです
間違っているのは人間の論理のこの方向性なんですね
故に金は悪なりと 針の穴からラクダが通るということはもう無理だからね
はっきり言うと 針と言ったっても
この知ってます？刺繍で使ってる小さな針なんですね
ニードルだからね 聖書の言葉は
バカでかい穴がある針ではないんです
そこはラクダにはちょっと通りにくいんですね
ですからもう天国に行く道でしょ
その入り口 それぐらい小さくなりますから
だから天国に行けないんですね
事故死ちゃうでしょうに
だから故に金が悪なりと
いうのはおかしいんであって
それはもう明確に論理性ないんだからなんです
言って あなた方のすべての財産を全部もう
宗教団体 そこも怪しいところなんですね
海に捨てろというならばね
正しいんです イエス様は正しかったんです
彼が渡してくれと言ってないんです
捨ててこいと だからイエス様が正しく言ったんです
もうお金が捨ててこいと全部
海に捨ててもどっちでもいいんです
だから捨てるということと
俺にくれということは随分違うでしょうに
ですから もしあるカルト宗教がね
お金は悪ですから寄付しないと言ったら
やっぱりあなた方にとっても悪ですよと
一番大事な宗教団体だから
もっと大事に守ってあげなくちゃいけないんだから
もうあなた方のものを私はもらいますよと
と言うべきなんです 論理的には
ですから この頼る世界はね
ですから 必ずしもお金の問題に延々と喋りましたけど
あの 悪か善かということはやっぱりそんな決められないんですね
この場合によって お金が素晴らしい善になる
善になる場合もあるし
とんでもない悪になる場合もあります
そこら辺考えてほしい
どのように自分がそれを使っているかと
だからそこら辺で人間にいつでも判断する能力はあるなければならないんですね
そうやって世の中で我々にとっては頼るものはもうものすごいあります
奥さんに頼る 旦那さんに頼る
子供に頼る 親に頼る 社会に頼る
会社に頼る お医者さんに頼る
人々の知識能力に頼る
電車に乗ったって 運転する人の技術に頼ってるでしょうに
あれ結構簡単そうで難しいんです
飛行機に乗っちゃったら
まあパイロットに完全に頼ってないと
だからパイロットは一人でいろんな厳しい訓練を受けて受けて
で 他の人の命を守っているでしょうに
結構頼りになるんです
そういう風に世の中でいろいろ頼りになるものがありまして
それは決して否定しているわけではなくて
否定する 否定したいところは
この人間の考え方なんですね
そこら辺はもうちょっとおかしいと
逆に論理作ってはいけない方向で
これ文章で書くと左から右へ書くんだから
論理はそうやって左から右へ書いてるんだけど
この人間が右から左へ考えちゃうんですね
決して成り立たなくなっちゃうんです
全くおかしくなっちゃうんです
ですから 頼りにならないものといっても
まあ物はもう考え次第だからね
使い次第だからね 使い方によって何でも頼りになりますよ
考え方次第 使い方次第
それで考え方 使い方間違ったら何一つも頼りにならないんですよ
火に例えてみてください
火は使い方次第で大変役に立ちます
非論理的に使うと終わりと全て
そういうわけだから 人間に本当にこの安全に危険を乗り越えるために不安
乗り越えて楽に生きているためには必要なのは何でしょうかと
答えがあるんです 結局必要なのは論理性なんです
それなければ何があっても役に立たないんです
ですから 結局頼りになるのは何ですかと
そういうところにはいきますけど
で そこはことを言うんだからといって
これから仏教の話をしますけどね
そこら辺話すんだからといって
この世の中の人々の頼りになるものは否定しているわけでもないんです
使い方次第だと で 私は今まで言ったのは
このみんな誰でも人はね
お医者さんは大変助けになりますよと
親も助けになりましたよと
まあ家族もよく助けになりますよとか
仕事も助けになりますよというぐらいのことは知ってます
でも 頼りというところでは
そういうことではなくて
もっと変なこと その世界で我々は論理性じゃありません
時々親が子供は自分の夢だと
希望だと 自分の命だと
あれ病気なんですね それでいい結果にはなりません
子供は必ずも親が言うことを聞かなくちゃいけないんだと
もう病気なんです 精神的に非論理的であることは当たり前なんです
必ずもではなくて まあ親が言うことを適当に聞くべきですよ
それだけのことなんです
なんだかんだ聞くというのは
飼ってる動物じゃないんだから
鳥籠で飼ってるオウムじゃないんだから
それ自体も言うことを全て聞かないでしょうに
動物飼っても それなのに自分の子供だったら
何でも自分言うことをやってくれなきゃ気が済まないんですね
そこで忘れているのは
自分が情けない人格で
性格ができてなくて 生きる目的何もなくて
子供を虐囚ではなく搾取していることなんですね
子供の生き方 子供の命を
だからそれで偉そうに宗教やら世界の話やら
いろんなものを勉強したりして
まあ子供いじめようと
もし宗教家でも子供っていうのは親の言うことをよく聞くべきですったらすごく喜んでくれるんですね
私たちにはそういう経験よくあるんです
時々大人が頼むんですね
同じ仏教の 私たちの宗教
宗派を信じている人々の中ではね
お坊さん この子供たちに何とか説教してくださいと
言うことを聞かないんだと
狙いは明確なんですね
で 別に子供たちに知恵を現れてほしくて
立派な人間になってほしくてということじゃなくて
自分の奴隷にしたいんですね
親は知ってるんだから
仏教はいかに親に対して子供の性格はどのようにするべきかと
もうしっかりと教えているんだから
そこら辺はもうお坊さんの口から子供たちに言ってほしいと
言って自分がいい気分で偉そうにお殿様の感じで子供を奴隷にしちゃおうという気持ちでしょう
そこでお坊さんも人間だからね
そのその次第にその人の希望を聞いて
リクエストに応じて 古臭い曲を回す場合もありますけど
私は回せません 要するにリクエストに応じません
すごいことになるんで
私にそんなこと頼むやったら
何回もあったんですね
で 一回のケースがあってね
まあ子供たちにはやっぱり親を尊敬しなくちゃいけないんだと子供たちに偉そうに言って
子供たちの反応はなぜ？そこでこのバカな親には答えられないんですね
自分たちが仏教徒だから仏教を知ってるつもりですけど
まるっきり知ってないんですね
知ってるんだったら答えるはずでしょうね
言ったらやっぱりこのアメリカンスクールのせいだと
[終始背景音楽]だからもう困ったもんだと
それで私に言うんですね
これなんとか子供たちにも何かこのだから
You have respect your parentsと言ったところで Why do you respect
parents?というふうに逆に聞い聞い聞い聞えたんだ
聞いたんだと 答えられなかったと
そんな調子で大人になったら困ると
で 私もああそう まあなんとか言おうかなと
説法の時は大人に説法してたんですね
子供を置いておいて それで終わったら子供たちも味方に回って一緒に遊んだだけ
遊んじゃっただけ 全然言わなかったんです
そんな子供を勝手に奴隷にしようと
それじゃなくて なぜと聞いたところで答えるのは親の責任でしょうに
変なことを言った自分が間違っていたでしょうに
ですから このそうやって世の中いろいろおかしいところがあるんですね
確かに子供が親いうことを聞くべきなんです
だ それだけのこと それ以上それはもう宗教的な言葉にして
神の言葉にして 絶対的な存在に持ってきて
絶対的に親に従うべきですよと
人間というのは絶対的な国に従うべきですよとか
よく言うこと 国いうことであろうとも
適当に従うべきである
私が言ったのは法律であろうとも
完璧に従う必要はない
適当に なぜかというと
法律がおかしいんだったら
人間がそれに反対して法律を変えなくちゃいけないんですから
冗談じゃない 決まりだからと
法律だからといって人いじめとかね
不公平なこととかね 世の中で何でも変えるでしょうに
法律さえも変えちゃうでしょうに
変えて変えていくでしょうに
それのに逆に法律だから守れというんですね
そういうのはバカな生き方であって
法律だからといって守るんではなくて
親言うんだからといって聞くんじゃなくて
課長言うんだから聞くんじゃなくて
そこに正しいんだからやるんだと
論理性あるんだからやるんだと
で なければ断ると そのような頼り方を仏教は語っているんです
だから加えて言いたいのは
この このいろいろ占いとかね
法医学とかね スイ何て言ったっけ
あれは あのえ？スイス？風水
風水に頼るとかね 星占いに頼るとかね
そういうとこ だからもう気持ちは分かりますよ
私も 将来は不安だから
親に聞いても分かりませんだからね
ですから まあ占いなどに頼ったりする
で そこまでは問題ないんだけど
占っても占っても大体はまあもう
例えば親に聞いたら まあお母さんも私に来年結婚できるでしょうかねと
母さんはまあなんでできないんですかね
できますよと いい相手見つかります
必ずは見つかりますよと
親は言うんです もう言っても別にそれは分かりませんね
本当にいい相手見つかるかないかっていうことは
占い師に行ってみてください
同じことです 大体もう占いっていうのはそれぐらいの世界で
風水のもうちょっとテレビで見たんだけどね
風水はもうもうもうなんて言いますか
不浄はものすごく嫌うんだと
それぐらいだったらもう幸せになるのは当たり前です
家の中は綺麗に丹念に丁寧に整理して
ものすごく見た目よく
気持ちよく 美しくね セットしておけば
誰でもしっかりするようになっちゃうんです
別にこれ北は南で鬼門はどちらかとかね
そんなものなくたって
でも今のマンションの情報を見ると
この風水で決めるところに台所作れますかね
ベッドなんかはね もうそちらで決めるところ作れますかね
その時平気で言うんですね
なんとか紙でもいいんだからそこに貼っておいてくださいと
だからインチキということははっきりわかるでしょう
確かに台所はこちらにあるべきですよというならば
ちゃんとしてそちらにあってほしいんですけど
私の論理から見れば で
そちらへ言うのをだったらこの食器ぐらいでもそちらに置いてくださいと
そちらにタンスをつけて
そこをタンスと言うんですか
そういう棚を作って 食器とかそちらに置いてくださいと
そこで あの まあまあいろいろありますけど
悪口とか知らない世界だから
そこで まあそこは置いといて
よくまああることは 例えばこのまあ自分の国とその文化のことを言いますけど
インドでもスリランカでもよくこの占ってみるんですね
星占いで そこで計算して計算してなんとか語る
それで気に入らなかったら次の人のところに行く
気に入らなかったら次の占い師のところに行く
決して信仰だけは捨てません
あの占い師はもうダメですねと
他のところに行く それずっとその話
だからずっともう もう三千年も経ってるんだけど
いまだにもうやってるんです
何やってるかと 人間は論理的になれば一番いいと思います
自分の国ももう捨てたもんじゃないんですよ
その点では 選挙終わって国会は初めて集まるでしょ
その日にちは占いで決めるんです
公ではないんだけど もうちゃんと自分に気に入っている誰かに
で決めてもらうんです
で 国会解散するときも
そういう自分の党が勝てるような
もう組み合わせの時間決めて解散するんですけど
実際はそれでも嫌な政府は負ける
なのにあの信頼だけはずっとあるんですね
だから私はもう個人的にもよく知ってるんだから
この占いやってる人知ってるんだから
この連中いい加減だなと
もう私たちほども微かにも合理性ないんだと
時々あの このいろんなこの古いテキスト見ながらね
この星のことやらね この星でこうなる
この星でこうなるって言うんだけど
それ読みが違うんじゃないかと
テキスト見て私から見れば
これ違うんじゃないかと
あなたの読みがと言いたいところあります
決まりで言っちゃうんですね
だから面白いことは この政治
政権与党 政治与党って悪いことばっかりやって
人いじめやら人殺しやらやりたい放題のことをやって
賄賂やらそこで国会を解散するときはちゃんと自分をすごく信頼している占い師に頼んでもらって
あのどんな日で解散すればいいか
それでこの日で解散してください
それで必ずあなたが勝ちますよと
そこでその政治家の生まれた時期に合わせて
この選挙の日程を決めて
すべて決めちゃうんです
そう決めたところで それ大体バレますから
この占いの新聞もあります
そう 占いの新聞もこのもうよく宣伝するんですね
今度こそはこの政府は倒れませんと
なぜならば星がここにいて
あちらにいて こちらにいて
こういうこういう組み合わせだから
でも結果としては完璧に負けちゃう
で 負けちゃったら占いがおかしいということで
その場合はどうなるかというと
ライバルの占い師の新聞社がね
あの新聞はダメやと 一向にこの人間のこの変な思考は消えません
例えば占いの新聞が 2つあると
お互いライバルでしょ
政府を応援するだったら
他の新聞が政府の反対側野党応援しちゃうんですね
だからそういうことで
それよりあの 私は今の状況を見ていたいのは
今もう女の人 大統領で頑張ってますけど
もう占いのところはそれほど興味ないんですけどね
すごいもう気が強くて
で でも厳密に正直なんです
それだけは言えるんです
宗教にお願いする？そんなことないよ
何か言ったら言って怒ったりもするし
でもまあ公ではあまり言わないんだけどね
ですからまあ逆に宗教と占いに頼るところよりも
このすごい自分がやることは厳密に正直
だから誰かがおかしいことをしたら
すぐそれには怒鳴りつける
自分の大臣の一人でも何かおかしいことしたったら
ものすごくすぐもう首をとぐか
もう厳密に調べて それなりに法律で裁くかと
だからあまりにも正直で頑張っちゃうんだから
誰にも抵抗できなくなっちゃうんですね
今選挙なんですけど 大統領選挙で
そこで野党側の議員たちがどんどんどんどんこの人を応援しているんです
たくさん来て応援しているんです
あれ見たら これはスリランカだったらありえない現象なんですけど
すごい政治的なもう悪神だから
向こうは マス神だから他にやることはないしね
[笑い]ですから そこで私がもう日本にいて
このインターネットで新聞を見ながら考えたのは
いくらなんでもあの女の人はもうもう頑固で正直もんだと
だからみんなにどうしようもないんだと
敵に回すわけにはいきません
敵に回したら危ないんだと
みんな裏に何かあるんだから
心の中に だから自動的に敵が消えちゃうんだと
その場合は占いは関係ないんですね
彼女はあまり欲しい占い手ではありませんだからね
ですから 人間っていうのはこういう自分の人生
先が不安だから いろんな占いなんかにも頼ったりする
でも何もやってくれないでしょう
分かったんだからといって
ですから この論理性はあってほしい
で 遊びでは別にどうったことないし
楽しみの一つとして まあまあどうってことないんだけどね
日本でもいっぱい占いのつぶて
縁起物前もって印刷して
それでくじ引きような感じで引いて
それでよかったよかったと
決してあちら悪いこと書いてないんだ
向こうの商売だから だったらもう人間の運命というのは事故に遭うこともあるし
突然病気になって倒れることもあるし
突然死ぬこともあるし
そういうものも書いておけばいいでしょう
みくじとなんとかというんですけどね
あんたはこの一年以内に病死
病気で死にますよとかね
事故を起こして寝たきりになりますよとかね
そういうこともあるんだけど
全然書いてないんですね
書いてるのはいいことしか書いてないんですね
だから結局わかりやすく
そちらの維持するための必要な商売だから
まあやってるだけで 別にそれ以上意味がないんですね
だからそこら辺もまあちょっと聞いた方がホッとするんだと
占い師にちょっと手相占いでも見て
なんかちょっとホッとしますよぐらいだったらいいんです
それだけだ だから例えば手相占いとあなたはすごい立派な金持ちになるんだな
気持ちがわかったと でもこいつが言うんだからと私は金持ちになる
私は頑張らなくちゃいけないというふうな理解あるならば
それで構いませんだけど
とことん頼ることはよくないんですね
だから占い私は別にあまり反対しませんだけど
信じてはないんだけどね
皆様やりたければとことんやってもいいんだけど
その場合もちゃんと計算
頼る量があるんですね
ちょっと心配しているんだったら
どうですかね 占ってでもくれませんかと
聞いてもらってもいいんだけど
それ以上何もないということを理解してほしいんですね
占い師に何でもしてあげることはできるわけじゃないんです
そういうことで 頼るのはよろしいですけど
明確に一つ一つついて計算した上で頼らなくてはならないんですね
だからもう裁判にもなるでしょうね
お金騙し取っ 騙して取られたんでしたとかね
で 宗教家が占ってあげて
あなたは癌になるんだと
そう言ったところで もうじゃあそれは何とかして除霊してあげなくちゃいけないな
そういう除霊儀式にはもうどんどんどんどんお金取られたでしょうに
そこで人のこの情けない性格をよくも使用されていますよ
なんで世の中でこの超能力者がいるかというと
我々は情けないだからなんです
腰抜けだからなんです
いるはずがないんです
我々はあまりにも情けなくて
それで夢作るんですね
あればいいなと あればいいなと思ったら
もう出ること出る事 あっちこっち
超能力者たちが 預言者たちが
そこで私たちは預言者に
超能力者に頼る その人を超能力を持ってるんだと言ったら
まあ超能力を持ってるんだったらいいんです
別に この立場から喋ると
もしAさんに超能力あるならば
じゃあ頼ってみますと
それは構いません でも論理性を失ってはいけない
どういう論理性か  Aさんの超能力は何でしょうかと
その能力 私に必要ですかと
だったらこれ じゃあお願いしますと
例えば ある人がハンドパワーでリウマチを治すとする
それ超能力なんですけど
で だからって人類みんなその人のところに行く必要ありますか？ないでしょうに
だったら龍脈の人が行けばいいんです
そこで中国風なこの気功のところであれ
どう正しいかどうかわかりませんだけど
なんか人を倒れちゃうとかね
もう倒しちゃうとか 動かしちゃうとか
いろんなことをやっていて
みんなびっくりと驚く
テレビで見たんだけどね
手をなんかこうやって変な風に人が踊ったりすると
ああ すごいすごいと それで終わっちゃうんだよ
だから私が聞きたいのは
もしそれ事実であったならば
ただ人がこうやって手を振る
踊っただけでしょうに
でもそこで止まらないで
その人宗教家になる 万能の人間になる
全知全能の態度をとる
あ 来ていらっしゃい いらっしゃい
何でもいいんで 私が回復してあげますよと
あれは我々のこの情けない性格だから
ああいうことを言うんです
だからあの人の能力を否定する必要ないんです
その人は手を出して もう気の力で人を倒したならば
それはそれでいいんです
だから倒してほしい人がそちらに行って
私も倒してくださいと
でお金払って倒してもらってもいいんです
私はもう倒してほしくないんだから行かない
怪我するんだから ですから
この能力 超能力あるかないか
我々にはもう調べることはできませんし
みんな偉いんだからね
近寄ることもできないし
だったら向こうが宣伝している能力は何ですかと
そこは自分に必要な品物かないかと
知った上で買えばいいでしょうに
なんで我々はあの大根買うためにはカメラの店に行かないでしょう
大根買う時は本当にいい八百屋さんのところに行って
信頼できるところに行って
あるいは有機栽培で作っているところや宣伝書いてるところにでも行って
調べて調べて買うのに
自分の命の場合は調べません
なんでも一人の人がやってくれると思う
そこは頼るところの我々のおかしいところなんですね
頼るのは悪くないんです
この目のやり方はおかしいと
ですから今あの現代世界であるこの
いろいろな迷信やらね
オカルトやらね 超能力ブームやら
そういうのはもう出てきているところはね
全部そうやって論理的におかしいんですからね
例えば人がスプーンを曲げたかもしれません
なんとかのパワーで だからといってその人を神ですよと
すべて知ってる 私のがんも治してくださいと
私の子供の頭勉強できないんだから頭を治してくださいというのは何なのかと
なんで普通の常識で考えないんですかと
その人にスプーン曲げることできるんだったら
家にあるすべてのスプーン持っていって曲げてもらえ
曲げてもらえばいいんですからね
私は行きませんだけどね
その場合も 曲げてほしくないんだから
私だったらこの この鉄筋コンクリートを作る時は鉄筋とか曲げなくちゃいけないで
それを持っていくんです
ここら辺で曲げてくださいと
だからおかしいっていうのは
誰もそれ持っていかないんですね
そういうスプーン曲げる能力ある人が
そういう 何といいますか
このもうconstruction worksいわゆるそうやって建設業者のところに行って
もう機械より早くもう曲げてまあいいでしょうに
そうすると電気代も儲かるし
人件費も儲かるし 公害もないしね
だからもしかするとそういう能力はあるかもしれませんですけど
その使用する我々はおかしいんですね
ある昔テレビで見たんだけど
このある女の人が これも宗教家なんですけどね
なんか男の人ばっかりで女の人少なかった
たくさん集めてもうお金すごい払いますけどね
そこでなんかいろいろこうやったら
それでみんなもう踊るんですね
この手の動き方によって
なんでやりますかって言われて
なんかすごいパワーがあって
どうしてもどうしても体が動かさなくちゃいけないんだと
[笑い]だから ものすごい気持ち悪い
ニコニコと笑ってニコニコと可愛くないんですけどね
なんか奴隷みたいな感じで
女王様みたいな感じで
人とそうやって操るんですね
だからまあ機能はわかりますけど
私も でも彼女がこの集会に行く前に
ちゃんとプロ中のプロの美容師のところに行って
すごくもうおしゃれをして
服やら全部もう髪型全部決めていくんですね
だからヴィジュアル系すごく考えているんですね
そこで神のごとく現れるんですね
舞台に現れて人をバカにしてもう帰っちゃいます
大量にお金もらって だからあれ何なのかと
何か役に立つんですかと
あんなことを して もし彼女に何かすごいパワーがあったかもしれませんだけど
もうないとないんですけど
でもあったならば ただもう人をこうやって踊らせることだけなんですね
でもあれはエアロビクスのインストラクターにもありますけどね
すごい力があるエアロビインストラクターいるんですよ
あれ始めたらもう踊らずにいられないんですね
すごく はいはい やりましょう
やりましょうと はい  1
2  3と言いながらね 音楽に乗って踊っちゃうと
あの明るさとあの元気さと見ると腰が痛いとか言っていられなくなっちゃうんですね
誰かがなんか遠慮して
手でもつなげて もう一緒にあれすると踊っちゃうんで
あれも同じパワーなんです
それで元気になると だからその場合は正しいんです
エアロビックインストラクターに頼る
何のために？体の健康のために
だから全然裁判はないんです
エアロビインストラクターにお金取られたんだと
私は元気にしてあげると約束で
でもあんまり元気にならなかったと
裁判起こしたって負けますからね
なぜかというと はっきりしているんだから
こういう運動で体は健康になるんだと
だからって運動したんだからと
万人が健康になるという約束はないし
体にいろいろ調子もありますから
それによってうまくいかない人もある
その人はやめればいいんです
そういうことだから この頼る時は我々は何をするべきかと
きちんとした論理性を持つべきですね
そうすると安全なんです
そうでないとどうなるかわからないんですね
だから世の中のやり方っていうのは
肉を切るんだから 魚もうお肉を売ってる店に行って
自分のお腹も切って手術してもらうのことなんですね
なんかいますよ すごい上手な人
もう 2 3 分で鶏なんかはね
丸ごと鶏だったらすぐ全部分解して
ちゃんとパックにして
はいどうぞという 私もある日一回だけ見て見たんですね
あの手早いということ
すごく早いんですね ささっと切ってパックにして
はいどうぞと ちょっと前に会ったのはただの死んだ鶏でしたけどね
そういう風にこの上手だから
包丁さばきは自分が盲腸になったらそこに行ってみればね
でも我々はこの頼る世界でそういうことをやってるんです
だから世の中で頼る世界ではいっぱい問題が起きてるんです
なぜかというと 簡単な答え
我々は論理性を持ってないんですね
あの お肉屋さんには自分の盲腸のことは頼まないでしょうに
論理的だから だからお肉屋さんに手術したケースは一つも世の中でないんです
手術されたケースは そこで十分 OK でしょう
我々はお肉屋さんに頼っている
お肉を買ってきて料理作って食べると
それで終わります お医者さんも結局もうかなり手が上手でしょうね
だからといって我々は一度も外科のところに死んだ鶏を持っていかないんですね
マグロ 1匹持って行って
これちゃんと切って刺身のようにちゃんとやってくださいと
あなた上手でしょう とは言わないんです
そちらには論理性あります
ですから この迷信の世界と
特に宗教の世界の頼るところでは
論理性ないということは我々の危険になっているんだと
そこはよく理解して 頑張らなければならないんですね
じゃあこの話のまた二部がございまして
ちょっと一休みをしてから次に始まります
ありがとうございます
第二部始まります  今までの話をまとめた一言で言うと
何でも頼りにならないわけじゃないんですね
我々の論理的な合理的な判断の中で
何でもうまく ことを使うことはできます
それで いまだに人間は
大勢の人間はそうやって生きてきたんです
危険を起こす人っていうのは少ないんですね
大体はもう大勢の人々はあまり危険を起こさない
それだったらもう生きていられませんから
ですから この適当に電気に頼って
お金に頼って いろんなものに頼って
我々はもう社会に迷惑をかけないで
危険を起こさないで生きてきたんです
でも 時々一人二人ぐらいおかしい人が出てきて
大きな迷惑をかけちゃうんです
ですから もう散々と私は大変な批判的な言葉を言ったかもしれません
だから この一般的には人間というのはそれなりに適当に頼って
まあ程よく頼って生活して幸せに生きているんですから
これちょっと崩れちゃったら大変だということなんです
ですから 気をつけて 我々はものに頼らなくちゃいけないと
まあ一応まとめてお釈迦様のことをまとめて言うならば
どっちにしても自分の判断
自分の判断というのは大変大事なことなんですね
ですから 結局頼りになるのは誰ですかと
お医者さんですか？と
お金ですか？と ではないんですね
お医者さんに対して私はどんな態度を取るかと
お金に対して私はどんなやり方をするかということでしょ
親が頼りになるかというと
そうじゃないんですね
私と親との関係はどのようになっているかということによって
頼りになった なったりならなかったりしますね
ですから 結局頼りは自分しかないと
そういうお釈迦様の有名な言葉がございます
アッターヒアッタノーナート
すいません ちょっとこれは
アッタのナート 自分の頼り
自分の主人 自分の救い主
どんな意味でもいいんです
このアッタというのは自分の
ナートというのは頼りなんですね
自分の頼りはアッターヒ
自分であると ヒっていうのは強調の言葉
デフィニティ 確かに自分こそ
自分こそ自分の頼りですよ
コーヒッナート パロシア
パロ 他人のところでは
他人ではナート 頼りはコーヒッ
あるか ありません 他人に頼る
他人に頼って何になりますって意味なんですね
これはちょっとレトリィって
まああるか あるかというふうな感じで
ありますかと 他人のところに頼りというものはありますかと
自分こそ自分の頼りであると
まあそういう結論は今までの喋ったことから出てくるんですね
だから誰にも悪口言う必要ないんですよ
世の中にいる人々に 泥棒に悪口必要ないんです
泥棒はそれを仕事をやってますからね
自分が自分の家を守ればいいんです
例えば我々はね 我々を守ってくれると
あの警察に頼るでしょ
守ってくれませんね 結局は
だからやっぱり自分がしっかりしておかないと
なんだかんだ守ってくれるということは
これ不可能なんですね
できませんしね そういうわけで
仏教は延々と人間はしっかりするべきですよと
そうでなきゃ大変不幸になりますよといいます
じゃあ次に問題 危険ってなんですかと
危険って何でしょうか
そこを重ねられちゃうとキリがないんですね
何でも危険なんですね
薬も危険 食べ物も危険
でしょうね 食べ物をね
まあ美味しい美味しいからと油いっぱいあるものを食べてみたら
コレステロール溜まっちゃうし
美味しいんだからとでお饅頭とかね
もうバクバク食べちゃったら糖尿病になっちゃうし
そうならなくたってもね
もうもう暇暇になって太ってしまっちゃうし
食べ物も危険 電車も危険
飛行機も危険 もう危なくて危なくて
だから危険と言えばすべて危険なんです
子供扱う場合はだいたい子供の面倒見の女性の方々でしょ
危険です あれ 子供に迷惑かけた数か数すべて女性です
すべてではなくて まあ九十パーセントが女性なんです
で この間 あのエジプトの飛行機でしたっけね
落ちたんですね アメリカで海に
あれ あのパイロットが飛行機を上に上げるように
このあれ 舵をね 前に引いてるところで
コパイロットが下引いてるんです
だから下引いたらディープダイブといきなり飛行機が鼻の先が下向くんです
ちょっとでも角度変わったら強烈な勢いで飛行機が動いているものだから
それでアメリカの方がそれは自殺ではないかと
と決めて それにイスラムの国は怒って
イスラムの信者さんは決して自殺はしませんと
まあ怒りますけど そういう自分の宗教の名誉を守るかね
事実調べるかって そこはもう考えないでね
だからお祈りしていたんではないかと
で いうのは正式的には死ぬ時はそういうお祈りはしません
まあそれはどっちでもいいんだけど
危険であることだけは確かなんですね
パイロットでもおかしくなっちゃったらどうなるかわからない
そこでこの間 この東京のどこかでね
だからもう想像できないんでしょうね
自分でいつでも子供を抱いたり
もう体を触ったり 毎日毎日可愛い可愛い可愛いとね
あまりにも可愛がっていると
どんな子供でも可愛く見えるはずでしょうに
それであっという女の子捕まって首を絞めて殺すということは
なんかちょっと想像できないでしょうね
あれは男にはできないと思いますけど
いくらなんでも ですから
危険と言えばもうみんな危険なんです
だから一番先に子供を虐待するのは誰ですね
母親でしょうに 隣のおばあちゃんが虐待しませんだからね
だから世の中というのはそうやって子供を守るのは誰ですかというと
それは母親であります
子供を虐待するのは それも母親なんです
そんなもんなんです で
世の中で 例えばこの危険だからこそ
安全対策 安全対策いっぱいあるんでしょうに
新幹線にしたっても 電車にしたっても自動的に止まると
運転士がブレーキをかけなかったら自動的に止まると
飛行機にしたっても もう一旦離陸したら
あのオートナビゲーションで
こう 何と言いますか オートパイロットで行くでしょうに
それで厳密に計算して
目的地用にコンピューターに
組み込んで それから地上からいろいろデータを取って
データを取って まあ飛行機が目的のところまで行くと
それで最終的なところに行ったら
また人間がそれを降ろしちゃうと
なんでそこまでやってますかというと
安全のためなんです だから一旦飛行機は空にある時はずっとどこかで地上から管理しているんです
ずっと それで安全と言いたいところですが
それでも飛行機が落ちる
そういうことですから
世の中で我々は耐えているものはものに限って五分五分
危険性も頼りになることも五分五分であることをわかってほしい
ポケットに入れてお金持って歩くと
まあ何でも簡単に買えて安心なんですけど
同時に誰かにやられる恐れもあります
お金やら宝石やらダイヤやら持っているのは楽しいかもしれませんだけど
同時に自分も殺されて全部盗まれる可能性もあります
すごい高級スピード出せるものすごい高級な車を持っているのはいいんだけど
ちょっとでも足をちょっと押さえたところで死んじゃう可能性もあります
だから馬鹿にならん方がいいんですね
夢中にならん方がいいんですね
物事に 気をつけた方がいいんです
頼るといえば何でも頼りになる
犬猫も頼りになる ちょっと気持ち悪いなとかね
ちょっとなんかちょっとあまり機嫌が良くないな
ちょっと外を見てください
よく木とかね その中に小さな鳥とかね
隠れているのを見ると
それ楽しいでしょうね
それで気が晴れますからね
気持ちよくなります それも頼りなんです
で 私のお風呂にこの 1 ミリぐらいの小さな虫
2匹いるんです あれ羽がついていて
今 2日  3日  4日もいますけどね
で あっちこち飛んだりもします
だからお風呂でもシャワーしてるんだから
シャワーしちゃうとこれ心配で心配で
むずさっと小さいんだからね
でもうまく逃げるんですね
どこから入ってるかわかりません
とにかく で この間  1匹がもう飛んで下の方に止まっちゃったんですね
下の方に止まっちゃったら
もう水に流されてしまうことはもう明らかでしょうね
それは無視してもうもうさわやっちゃってもいいんだけど
それはできないんだから
なんとかちょっとちょっとシャワーをやめて
ドアの方に引っ張って外へ出しちゃったんですね
外へ出しちゃったらまた心配なんですね
もう 1匹いるんだから
あれ夫婦でいるんだから
だからあまりに小さい虫にこのドアの外に出したっても
かなり距離がある 大きいでしょうね
やっぱり夫婦別れ別れさせちゃって悪いことしちゃったなって
だからそこはなんか虫が入って嫌だなと思ったら
もう気持ち悪いしね 私はそういう目で見てなかったんだから
まあそこで夫婦で仲良くしてるんだと見たところで楽しくなるだけで
それも頼りといえば頼りなんですね
一人でいる私にとっては
ちょっと 1 ミリぐらいのちょっと飛ぶ虫が 1 匹いていて楽しいと
だから今日も元気でいるかな？って開けてみるんです
どこにいるかなと だからといって私が私の部屋で虫いっぱい育てるべきかと
ですから 頼りになる同じものが迷惑にもなる場合があります
そういうことだから 世の中であるものは何でも五分五分で
使い方次第で頼りになるかならないか
大変な危険になるかっていうどちらにもなります
ですから 医者も人を殺すんだから
我々は知識を持つべきなんです
そうすると殺せないんです
裁判を起こせるんですね
日本ではもう何でも秘密主義だからね
カルテは見せません 病名は説明しません
病気は治療法を説明する
偉そうに あんな秘密主義では人殺すためでしょうね
おそらく ですから 自主教まで何でも学校の記録ですか
それは教えませんとかね
なんであれと分かりませんだけどね
まあ現地人だと思ってるんだから
ですから やりたい放題
学校でも子供の評価はやりたい放題でとか
ですから まあなんだかんだでも知らせた方がいいし
我々も調べた方がいいし
それで我々もその判断能力を持った方がいいし
そうするとお互いに我々はちゃんとあまりにも頼るそこともしないで
まあ何て言いますか それなりの言葉あるでしょうね
それなりに生活は幸せにできます
そういうわけで 人間にとっては本当の危機は飛行機でも自転車でもないんです
嫉妬で怒っていたお母さんでもないんです
子供殺した 人間にとって本当の危機は何でしょうかね
それは我々の頭なんですね
で 最強に怖いもの それは我々の頭なんです
我々の無知なんです これはものすごい古い経典で
このスッタニパータであって
この訳は私がもうあせって勝手にやったんだから正しくないことは確かなんですけど
中村先生のテキスト調べて正しい訳を見てください
ケーナ
ッスニュートールーオーケーナッスナンパカーセティキッサービラパナンルーシーギンスタッスマッバヤンというアジカというある哲学者がお釈迦様に聞くんです
まあ哲学者でもあるし
宗教家でもあるし 若い人でしたけどね
テーナスニウトロープ
ロープっていうのは世界ということで
この世 何によってこの世が覆われていますか？という
それだけでは意味は取れません
世っていうのはもう人間の生命のことなんです
我々は何かに覆われているんです
すごい暗い黒いベールに我々は隠さっていて
何もわからなくなってるんです
人生って何ですかとか
だから何に我々日本も覆われていますか
世の中 テーナスナッパカーセ
パカーセっていうのは表現していることなんですね
明確に現れていることなんですね
なぜこの世 人生ですね
現れて 間違ってますね
現れてないのですか ここ間違ってます
なぜこの世の中は現れてないんでしょうか
だから現れてないでしょ
今もずっと我々は調べてるでしょ？探してるでしょ？生命って何ですか？何のために生きてるんですか？とかね
我々はどのように生きてればいいんですかとか
全然わかってないんです
いろんな人がいろんな説を言う
それに反対する人もいるし
だからたくさん宗教がありまして
たくさん哲学がありまして
たくさん生き方がありまして
老師も人とするし イエス様も人とするし
モハメドも人とするし
もうどちらがどちらかともうわからないんです
だから結局この世の中は現れてないんですね
自分がここで生きているのに
何でしょうかとわからないんです
何のために生きているんですかとわからないんです
それでキッサービラパナンブルース
これを私はすごく訳しにくかったんですね
表現 言辞 話す 語ることなんですけどね
とは何でしょうかということを訳したんだけど
おそらく合ってない可能性があります
いわゆる表現する 語る
説法する 啓示 神の啓示
これ何でしょうかということなんですね
だからすごい難しい質問なんですけど
でもアビラパニンという場合は
このここにアビラパナンという言葉がありますね
もう何かずっと唱える意味なんですね
あるいは人と話すことの意味もあります
あるいは普通に これは本です
これはカーテンです これは何々ですと世界の学問の世界で
これは何々ですという世界でしょ
これは地球です 地球は丸いですとかね
それは表現なんです いわゆる心理の表現なんです
だから表現というのは大変大事な言葉なんです
そこなければ学問も科学も何もないんです
これは地球です 地球は丸いですとかね
地球は自転していますとかね
そういうのは表現である
それで我々勉強するって
同じことを繰り返して繰り返してやってる
だからアビラパナンって何でしょうかと
表現というのは それでキースタッスマッハという偉大なる恐怖
タッス この人に 生きている私にとって偉大なる恐怖って何でしょうか？そこでお釈迦様はすばりと答えるんですね
アビジャミウトロープ
無明ということで 世の中そこはベールなんです
だからわからないんです
無明 無知 この世が無明で覆われていますと
そこでウェーリッチャパマーダナッパカーセ
なんで私が私のことをわからないかという質問に
私がここでハッキリと生きているのに
やっぱりわからない それで
生きてるのにどう生きるべきかわからないんです
そこでお釈迦様が言うのはウェーリッチャパマーダ
疑と怠惰 頭はしっかりしていない
いつでも疑ばっかしで
こうではないか ああではないか
私はこう思います こうだと思いますよとか
いいお釈迦様こうではないんですか？とかね
そればっかし何でしょうかとしっかりしようという能力
努力しないんです それから怠惰
いつでも なんて言いますか
やりやすい方法でやっちゃうんです
我々もそうでしょう 勉強しないで
調べないで 新聞であったら信じてしまっちゃう
テレビで言ったら信じてしまっちゃうとかね
だから図鑑とかね 百科事典とか引用するテキストいっぱいできたりしてね
じゃあ辞書を引いてみましょうとか
じゃあ百科事典引いてみようとか
すごい便利で そうやって便利な方法ばっかり探してるんです
それは頭の中でも物事を理解しようと思ったら
便利な方法でいっちゃうんです
怠惰 そこで問題なんです
私は神ですって ああそうですか
じゃあお願いしますと
随分便利ですね そのやり方は
あんた何で神ですか？とは調べようとしない
何故に神ですか？と調べようとしない
この怠惰怠慢の精神 だから世の中には一向に真理は現れてこないと
だから現れてこない ジャッパービラマナンブルーミット
この世の中に何が表現ですかというと
それは妄想ですよと ただ頭で考えてることばっかりだから
だからテキストやらがもういろんなもう思考
思考 思考ばっかりで いくら思考あったっても一人もわかってないでしょ？生き方
方法っていうのは だからもういくらあっても足らないし
毎日毎日いろんな思考が出ているっていうのがただのそれ教義
苦しみが偉大なら恐怖である
苦しみっていうのはもう最終的な結論で
例えば子供が病気になったら自分が苦しいと
だから病気になることから苦しみが生まれてくる
会社がクビになったら別にどうしたことないんだけど
やっぱり収入がなくなっちゃうと苦しみが生まれる
だからクビになるのは心配する
そうやって我々にはいろんな不満
いろいろあるんだけど
なぜ不満に困るかというと
不満で最終的には苦しみになりますから
病気になったら心配だと言うでしょ
別にそれはどうしたことないんです
問題は病気になったら後で苦しむから
ですから苦しみっていうのは最終的な問題なんです
全てはそこで終わっちゃうんです
苦しみ そういうことだから
一番怖いものは苦しみですよ
で このお釈迦様の言葉で我々は何を理解するべきかというと
やっぱりそこはすべて書いているんです
人間はやっぱり無明 無知は破らないと
ちゃんと論理的で ちゃんと具体的で
物事を考えないと それからこの精神的に
このこの簡単な方法で
便利な方法で物事を知ろうと
例えば病気になったら
まあお祈りするとかね
呪文唱えるとかね そこ便利な方法でやろうとするのはやめた方がいいんです
このファーストフードの論理でやらない方がいいんですね
ファーストフードこそ人類の将来の食習慣というのは大間違いであって
あれでもう死んじゃいますからね
たまたまいいかもしれませんだけど
ファーストフードだけこそ将来のというふうに言ってはいけませんね
やっぱり時間かけて手を込んだ料理は体にいいんです
ですから このそこはやってはいけないと
それで今答えがあります
それから 頭で余計なことを考えてはしゃべる
考えてはしゃべる 考えてしまう
それはやめた方がいいんです
そういうことで人間にはこの智慧が生まれてきます
で ついでにそれ全部言いますと
これはこの仏教の世界
仏教の人の頼りになりますけど
でもお腹が空いちゃったらね
私に聞くんじゃなくて
レストランに行ってください
仏教何でもやってあげるという約束ないんです
ちゃんと仕事を分担しているんです
結婚したらしたければ
私にいい相手を探してくださいと頼まないでください
知りませんから だからお釈迦様はちゃんとそれははっきりみんなに言ってるんです
でも宗教が違うんでしょう
何でも叶いますよと 何でも叶いますよと
あれこそ嘘なんです 仏教を信仰したんだからって
何でも叶うわけじゃないんです
仏教を信仰すると もういろんなものを失うこともあります
確かに 何でも叶うわけじゃないんです
ちゃんと仕事を分担しているんです
仏教の仕事は 心にある煩悩
憎しみ 怒り そういうものは全部消して
完全たる智慧を現わしてあげること
現れるようにすること
永久的に生きて死んで生きて死んで
この輪廻の限りなくこの苦しみをカットすること
はっきりとその仕事は決まっているんです
だから奥さんにどんなプレゼントをあげるべきかというならば
仏教に聞かない方がいいんです
それは 仕事をはっきりしています
それで仏教のおかげで経済活動はこの仏教の国というのは貧しいんだとよく言うでしょうに
経済活動はしないんだからと
別に仏教にそんな興味ない
仏教仕事をちゃんとやってますから
自分の仕事を思い存分やればよい
他人の仕事に口を出す必要ないんです
経済活動と政治活動は経済学者と政治家の世界であって
仏教の仕事じゃないんです
たとえミャンマーやスリランカやタイやらマレーシアと言ったっても
それはその政府が悪くて
経済学者が悪くて 国際的な経済状況は不公平だからそうなってるんであって
お坊さんのせいじゃないでしょう
私のせいだと言ったっても関係ないでしょうに
だからそう言う人がもう本当にもう気持ち悪いほど頭が悪いんです
仏教は自分の仕事をしっかりしているんです
ですから この心の問題を解決するのは仏教の世界です
アニッシトーのチャル
アニッシトーというのは
この最終的に見るとニッシタというのは頼ること
何にも頼らない人には揺れ動きがないと
このニッシタというのは頼ること
アニッシタというのは頼らないこと
チャル チャルというのは揺れ動くこと
だから我々は何かに頼るでしょう
ご飯に頼る 同時にまあお腹も満腹になっちゃうし
体力もつきますけど 病気にもなります
子供に頼っちゃうとこれ楽しいんだけど
同時に心配もある すべて五分五分でしょう
だから心の揺れ動きは一向に消えません
いくら経っても 外国旅行するのは楽しいなと思ったら
毎月毎月外国旅行したいんだと
それ楽しいですよ でもまた半分お金かかる
いろいろ危険に出会うとかね
そちらもあります だから心の揺れ動きはなくなりません
飛行機のパイロットは今
最新型の機器すべてついているんだから
もう百パーセント安全だよとはないんです
機械が優れれば優れるほど
失敗の確率も高いんです
だから たった二 三分でロケットが消えちゃったんだから
三百億円 言われるところじゃないんです
瞬時に消える あれは古いものだったら
じゃあもうちょっと直そうとかね
もっと引っ張ってまたということはね
最近最新型になっちゃうとできません
昔の車っていうのは そこら辺の鍛冶屋さんに誰でも修理できましたよ
そこら辺の鍛冶屋さん
誰にでもできる 今の車は故障しちゃったら廃車
廃車処分です 他の道がないんです
でも最新型 ですから この頼っても頼りになればなるほど危険性も五分五分あります
ですから いつまでも心の揺れ動きは消えません
子供は可愛ければ可愛いほど不満も多いです
不安というか心配も多いんです
そういうことを理解してほしい
ですから 頼りない人には心の揺れ動きはないと
ニッシトーチャウパーディアン
ニッシタというのはまだ頼ること
ウパーディアンというのはとらわれて執着していること
頼る 依存する とらわれる人がこちらからあちらへと回されると
イッターバーワー アンニャッターバーワー
こちらやあちら 全員あちらに回される
こちらに回される まあ分かりやすく言えば
私もあの学校に行って
そこの塾に行って そちらに行って
そうやっても我々ももう子供のこと可愛ければ可愛いほど回されるでしょうに
それだけじゃなくて 人間として生命として死んでも
また他のところに回る
そこに死んでまた他のところに
そうやってずっと人生が限りなく回されちゃうんですね
頼っちゃうと だから頼ると回されますよっていうことはすごい分かりやすいことなんです
サンサーラナートゥと言って
その人にはこの回されること
輪廻ということ 乗り越えられない
次にエタンアドーナワンナッジャッワー ニッサーエースー マハッバヤン
そこで頼ることには頼る
[背景音楽]頼ることから生まれるこの偉大なる恐怖を理解し
頼ると偉大なる恐怖が生まれます
その偉大なる恐怖からドゥッカが苦しみが生まれる
最終的には そこははっきりしてほしい
だから会社クビになったら心配と
で なぜかというと お金がなくなっちゃうと結局苦しみになるんだからなんです
ですから 何やっても最終的に残るのは苦しみだけですから
その偉大なる苦しみ 偉大なる恐怖を理解して
これ頼ることから生まれるんだと
比丘が頼ることなき とらわれることなく
気づきながら生活すると
これサティの生き方なんですね
ちゃんと理解して これはこういうこと
これはこういうこと ちゃんと理解してサトービクパリッバジー
やっぱり頼らない方がいいと
依存しない方がいいと
だから頼らないで依存しないで
まあしようしてはいけないというわけじゃないんです
子供の面倒見るんだけど
依存はしません 頼ろうとはしない
それだけ だから依存することなく
よく理解して生活すれば
そこに安らいが出てきます
で そこを理解して次のポイントに行きます
で 次のポイントといっても
まず結論から言いますけど
結局人間が心の問題でありったけの苦しみの網を作っているんですね
だからあの人すごいと
あの人を信じますというのは自分の判断でしょう
自分のすべて委ねますというのは自分の判断でしょう
法の華 なんとかにもう全部もう財産も委ね
これは自分の判断でしょう
結局は だから商売は失敗しても成功したっても
夫婦喧嘩になっても もう離婚になったっても
仲良くしたっても そういうすべて人間の心の働きの結果なんですね
だから問題は頼るか頼らないかということじゃないんです
あなたの心しっかりしているかいないかということなんですね
それが仏教の仕事 野菜作るのはもう百姓さんの仕事
だから仏教でもてどうやって美味しいキャベツ作れるかと聞くんじゃなくて
仏教に来てどうやって立派なしっかりした頼れない安全安心できる心が作れるかと
と聞くべきなんです 我々から見れば
それは一番土台であって
元であって それこそ人間まずやるべきなんです
美味しいキャベツする以前
自分の心を直すべきなんです
家庭の平和の安全のためにいろんな対策練るんじゃなくて
その前に自分の心を安定させなくちゃいけないんです
だからトラブルは心が作るんです
そういうことだから 心さえ安定してもらえば
心さえしっかりしてもらえば問題ないんです
ドゥッカがないんです
ということで 頼る必要なくなっちゃうんです
頼るということは乗り越えられる
弱いんだから頼るんですよ
怖いんだから頼るでしょ
で 実際心直す そこであの
時間なくて日本語にしなかったんだけど
ケーナスニーヤティローカ
この世の中はリードしてリードしているのは誰ですか？ケーナスパリカッサティ
操る人形のように自分勝手にいるままに
この世の中というのは我々人間のことなんですね
我々を誰に操られていますか？ヒッサスエーカダンマッサ
何か一つ誰かあるはずなんですよと
エーカダン エーカっていうのはワン
一つ ダンマっていうのはまあ物事ですからね
何か一つがありますよと
この我々を支配して好き勝手に操られている
サッベヴァサマナタ 我々はこの支配されているというか
我々を支配している この何か唯一のものあるんだと
それは何でしょうかと
ブッダに聞くんです ブッダの答え
チッテーダニーヤティローカ
世の中をリードしてガイドしているのは心ですと
チッテナパリカッセティ
我々は操られているのは
いろんな方法でいろんなままに操られているのは心ですと
心に操られているんだと
チッタッセエーカダンマス
この心という たったこの一つのものによって
サッベーワワサマンノク
みんな支配されている
心の支配されていて 心の奴隷であるということなんです
心は乗り越えられませんということ
歩くにも心を出すから歩きたいんだから歩く
座るにも座りたいんだから座る
寝るにも起きるにも ご飯食べることも全部そうでしょう
世の中にいくら綺麗な人いたっても
あの人をいいやつと自分で何もなくリクエストするのを決めるでしょ
心の勝手なんです そこで何か気に入ったら
好きになっちゃったら
悪いものは全部見ないようにする
悪いこともいいように解釈する
人は嫌になったらその人のいいところを悪いように解釈したりするとかね
やっぱり心の好き勝手なんでしょう
奴隷なんです 誰の奴隷かというと
神の奴隷ではなくて 心の奴隷なんです
それで終わります また同じ偈文
他のところでもありまして
それも同じ質問にケーナスネーヤティーローコケーナスパリカッセティキッスッシーエカダンマスサピーワサマンノクという質問にその違うところで答えるんですね
タンハー 渇愛が支配しているんだと
欲 渇愛 それからタンハーパリカッ
渇愛に操られているんだと
渇愛にみんな奴隷にされているんだと
渇愛 欲 生きていきたいという気持ち
で じゃあそれで仏教はじゃあダメやと人間がね
まあ渇愛しかないんだから
いわゆる心と心は乗り越えられませんだからまあ手上げましょうかと
それは小教なんそうなんです
神を乗り越えられます
だからこれ神の代わりに仏教は心と入れ替えているだけ
神は乗り越えられる お手上げでしょうに
だったら 言われる通りにやるしかない
仏教の違うところは抑えましょうと
神を だから今 神 神じゃなくて心に我々奴隷にされてるんですね
心に我々の自由を抑えられているんですね
そうでしょ？例えば人と仲良くしたいんだけど
心が嫌だというんだからね
人は憎しみたくないでしょ
でも憎しみちゃうでしょ
どうしようもないんです
人の過ちを許してあげたいんだけど
やっぱり心が嫌だと 憎しめと言っちゃうでしょう
だからはっきりと我々の心が我々をもう操っているんです
みんな立派になりたいと思いますけど
なれないんですね 心は嫌だと言ってるんだから
誰も悪いことしたくないでしょ
でもやっちゃうでしょうに
心はやりたいんだから
どうしようもないんです
それでどうしようもないかといって
手上げますか？手上げますかと
すみません 仏教はそこら辺ではすごい
もうなんて言いますか
凶暴というか乱暴というか
仏教は じゃあ心を抑えればいいと
そこをやっつければいいと
そういうことで 仏教っていうのは
この心を管理する世界
心を清らかにすること
世界 だからほとんど無理なことをやろうとしているんです
それは西洋的な分かりやすい宗教の言葉で言えば
この神をコントロールする世界
神を戒める世界であって
神をお祈りする世界ではないんです
神に説教していい加減にしてもらうと
神様お願いしますではなくて
だから神の代わりに仏教は心という言葉を使いますから
心に入れ替えて考えてください
だからすごい大胆なんです
だから科学者もやっていることでしょうね
この自然はもうなかなか乗り越えられない
大変なことですけど やっぱり黙っていないんですね
なんかもうチャレンジするでしょ
それで科学世界発展したような感じで
じゃあ心にチャレンジすれば心に勝てる
心が負けて自分が勝つと
それで自由が生まれていきます
そこは仏教の仕事 そういうわけで
この仏教では この人の病気治しとかね
豊作のためにお祈りとか
あんまり関係ない世界なんです
豊作のためにお祈りするんじゃなくて
ちゃんと科学的に勉強しなさいというのが
まあブッダから言えば言いたいところなんです
病気だったらお祈りするんじゃなくて
早くお医者さんに頼めと
だから なんで私もずっと自分の説法でそういうことをあんまり批判的に喋ってきたかというと
仏教は自分の仕事は明確に別にわかっているんだから
人の仕事に手を出さないんです
だから これ全て一人がやってくれるわけじゃないんです
音楽 音楽家は音楽を奏でてくれるし
絵画 絵画さんは絵を描いてくれるし
百姓さんは野菜作ってくれるし
漁師は魚を取ってくれるし
そこで成り立つんであって
すべて一人がやろうとするとすごい危険であっておかしいんです
宗教の世界で危険なところは全部自分でやるんだと思っちゃうところなんです
だからカルト的で 農業もそこでやってるし
病院も自分たちの病院作ろうとしているし
政府も自分たちの政府作ろうし
冗談じゃないんです 政府は政治家がやるんであって
宗教がやるものじゃないんです
病院はお医者さんたちが作るんであって
宗教が作るところじゃないんです
だから宗教の世界のところでいっぱいおかしいところがあります
お釈迦様は心を助ける方法
心に打ち勝つ方法を教えているのです
好きに出すプリントはなんかインクがすごく滲んでしまって
私は怠けて使い方 コンピューターで全部Wordで打たないで
全部スキャンしちゃったんで
そのままテキスト それで失敗しました
ですから使えないんで
そこは置いておいて うまいこと見せて
もう一つは経典一つ丸ごと読んでみましょうか
今の文字は綺麗じゃないと思います
これもWordに打ち込んだのではなくて
そのままプリンターに直接
スキャンしたんだからね
これどういうことですか？ピヤソッタンという
これちょっとしたこの我々どうするべきかと
ピヤっていうのは好きという言葉なんですね
大体の で まだ ピヤソッタンというのは
好きということ お釈迦様っていうのは
あなたは自分のこと好きでしょう
だったらしっかり死なない人
倫理的に生活しなさいということで
お釈迦様がサワッティの最上で教えたこと
エッ ゲシンノボー ラージャパセーディコーサラ
このコーサラ王様はバガヴァンタンエータデボージャン
お釈迦様にこう言ったんです
王様の考え方なんですね
イダマイヘンバンテーラホウガタッサパティサリーナッセ
お釈迦様 私はラホウガタッサ一人で
一人でシシダにいた時は
エーワン チェートソパリタットウッダバーリ
このような考え方が現れたんだと
ケーサンノコウピヨーアッター
ケーサンアッピヨーアッターティ
ケーサン 誰に自分のことを好きですかと
誰に自分のことを嫌いですかと
いわゆる自分自身のこと
自分自身のことを好きな人
自分自身のことを嫌いな人は誰ですか？そういう質問が生まれたんだと
タッサマイヘンバンテーエータダホース
そこで私にはこういうふうなことを考えましたと
エーチェコウケーチカーエーナドゥッチャリタンチャランティ
もし誰かがカーエーナ
体でドゥッチャリタンというのは悪いこと
いけないこと よくないこと
体でよくないやってはいけないことをチャランティ
行っているならば 次に
ワーチャイ ワーチャイ
言葉で これ じいさん出てくる
一応説明だけだったら vacchā
で言葉でduccaritaṃ carant
iやってはいけない言葉を喋るとmanasā duccaritaṃ caranti頭で考えてはいけない悪いことを考えたりするならば
tesaṃ appiyo attāその連中は自分のことを嫌いだと
だからわかりやすいんですね
あなたはあなたのこと好きですかと
あなたはあなたのことを嫌いですかと
ということを王様が考えたんですね
考えたところで もし人が体でおけちの悪いことをする
言葉で言ってはいけない言葉を喋る
頭で考えてはいけないことを考えるんだったら
あの連中は自分のことを嫌い
嫌い 嫌いだと 自分自身で自分のことを嫌いだと taṃ
kissahaīなぜならばyañhi appiyo appiyasakareyya t
aṃ te attanāva attanā karontiなぜならば
嫌いな人は嫌いな人にやることをその人々は自分にやってるんだと
わかりやすいでしょ 論理が
例えば私が嫌いな人はこちらにいる
殴っちゃうんですね 体に悪い行為でしょ
その人を嫌いだから 私は嫌いな人をこいつらにやる
口で悪口を なぜならば相手が嫌いだから
相手のことを私が嫌いだから悪口を言う
そこでこの人を私が嫌いだったら
頭の中でもその人のことを悪いこと考えたりする
死んでしまえとか考えていけないこと
そこで私が自分が嫌いな人にやることは
私が私にやってるんだと
もし私が体で自分でやってはいけないことをするならば
自分で喋ってはいけない言葉を喋っているならば
自分で考えてはいけないことを考えているなら
わかりやすいでしょ 私の敵が誰ですかと
私なんです あんたそんなにも自分のことを嫌いかと聞いた方がいいんですね
その場合 自分のことそんなにも敵かと
だから人間の非論理的なことっていうのが
自分は敵に回っている
自分のこと だから悪いことしているんです
そこでtasmā tesā appiyo attā ye ca kho keci kāyena sucaritaṃ carantiいわゆる逆
もし人が体でいいことをするならばvacchā sucaritaṃ caranti言葉でいいことをするならばmana
sā sucaritaṃ caranti
頭でいいことを考えるならばtesaṃ piyū attā体は自分のことを好きですよと kicchāti
te evaṃ vadayoでもこの人々はこう言うかもしれませんと appiyo
no attā athako tesā piyū attāこのいいことをする人々は口で私はこの人生嫌いですよとかね
もう輪廻はしたくないとかね
この生活はあまり欲だらけの生活
そうやって口でいろんなことを言うんだと
いわゆる正しく生きる人々は
お金もよくないんだとかね
やっぱりこういう人生って意味がないんだとかね
なんか暗いことを言うんですね
生きていたっても何の意味あるんでしょうかとかね
それで口先で自分のこと嫌いなことを言うんだけど
結局体では悪いことをしない
言葉では悪い言葉を言わない
頭では悪いことは考えないということは
この人は自分のことを好きですよと kiñcāti
te evaṃ vadayo appiyo no attā ti athako tesā piyū attā体には自分の命が好きだと
好きだと taṃ kissahaī yañhi piyo piyassa kareyya te attanā
va attano karonti tasmā
tesā piyūなぜならば taṃ
kissahaīなぜならば
人が好きな人にやることは
この人々は自分にやってるんだから自分自身
単純な論理なんですけど
明確な論理なんです この単純明確な論理っていうのは人生に必要なんです
王様っていうのは 例えば私に好きな人がいる
可愛い人がいると 私はその人に悪口言いません
もう体でも優しく触ったりする
言葉でも優しい言葉を言う
その可愛い人のことを頭の中でもすごく優しく考えたりする
これ他人が可愛い時でしょ
でも私自身で悪い言葉を言わない
体で悪いことをしない
頭で悪いことを考えないということ自体が
論理的に考えられちゃうと自分のことを可愛いっていうことですよと
でも本人に聞いたら あんたは自分のことをすごい可愛がってるで
とんでもない 私は輪廻脱出したいんだと
人生は意味がないんだということを言うかもしれません
でも本当は自分のこと好きですよ
お釈迦様の答え エーワ メッタ マハーラジャ エーワ メッタ マハーラ
その通りです王様 その通りです王様
そこで同じことをお釈迦様ここまで行くんです
だから長いんだけど 全部読まなくてもいいです
そこまでお釈迦様は同じことを繰り返して
あなた言う通りですよ
素晴らしい経典なんですね
だから私がもし悪口言ったり悪口言ったりするなら
私は私の敵なんです そう言ってるんです
だからこの大体仏教の人々の中でいるんですよ
このこういう経済活動やらお金儲けて何の意味もない物質文化なんかはね
もうない方がいいんだとかね
私はそういう世界はもう嫌いですよとかね
なんか暗いことばっかり言うんだけど
本当は自分では全然悪いことをしません
人殺したりもしません
助かる小さな虫でも殺しません
ということは 結局自分のこと好きですよという論理なんです
そこでお釈迦様の言葉がこちらにあるんです
アッターナンチェ ピアンジャンニャ
あなたはあなたのことを好きだと思うならば
ナナン パーペーナ サンユジェ
それは悪でごちゃ混ぜにするなら自分の性格
ナヒタン スラバン ホーティ スカン ドゥッカタ ドゥッカタカーリナ
ドゥッカタカーリナ 悪いことをする人にはスカン
幸せ安らぎというのはナヒタン スラバン
ほとんどないんだ スラバンというのはいっぱいあるということで
大勢にあるという その反対の言葉でそれほどないんだ
だから悪いことをする人もたまたま
せせせ 何て言いますか
幸せでいる時もありますけど
稀なんですね ですから
あまりないんだと アンタ テーナーディ パンナッサ ジャハトー マヌサン バワン キンニ タッサ サカンホーティ キンチャ アーダエ ガッチェティ
そこで仏教は自分の仕事に入るんです
アンタ テーナーディ パンナッサ
我々はみんな死にかけている
いくら金持ちであろうか
死ぬ 政治家であろうか
みんな死ぬ みんな死にかけている
あなたの確実確固たる死というところから考えたら
死に向かった時はジャハトー マヌサン バワン
人間としての生き方 ジャハ
捨てる時 あなたは人間として寿命を終える時は
キンニ タッサ サカンホーティ
あなたに何がありますか
ワット ドゥ ユー ハブ ウェン ユー フェイス デスという
意訳すれば簡単ですけどね
あなたはもう人生終わろうとしている
もう死のうとしている
今は あなた今何がありますか？と聞くんです
持ってるものは何ですか？今までの建物やら全部会社やら財産やら一つも持ってないでしょうに
その瞬間 キンチャ アーダエ ガッチェティ
これからあなた死ぬでしょ？死んでもあの世に行くでしょ
持っていくのは何ですか？と
アメリカに行く時はカバンとかね
いっぱい持っていくんだけど
じゃあ死んでいく場合は何が持っていくんですか？キンチャッサ アヌガン ホーティ
アヌガンというのは一緒に行く人
ですから 偉い人 どこかに行くといっぱい人々一緒に行くでしょ
フォロワーというかね
まあ後ついていろいろお手伝いするために一緒にいる人
キンチャッサ アヌガン ホーティ
あなたと一緒に行く人は何で誰ですか？と
チャーヤー アナパーイネ
あなたの影のように あなたは見放さないで
あなたの面倒を見て一緒に行く人は誰ですかと
ウボー プンニャンチャ パーパンチャ
ここで答えお釈迦様が言うんです
人に聞くんだけど 答えは聞かないんです
答えはお釈迦様出すんですか？ここで質問している
ウボー プンニャンチャ パーパンチャ
プンニャっていうのは徳
パーパっていうのは罪
ウボー 2つ両方自分が行った悪いことといいこと両方
ヤン マッチョー クルテ イダ
マッチョーというのは人
イダ この世の中でクルっていうのは行う
人間としてこの世の中で行ったいいこと悪いこと
その両方をタンニ タッサ サカンホーティ
それは彼のものだと タンチャ アーダエ ガッチェティ
それ持っていくんだと
ですから 会社の肩書きもお金も自分作ったマイホームを持ってるわけじゃないんです
自分がやったいいこと悪いこと持っていくんだということで
自分のことを好きたければ好きと思うならば
そういう風にいいことをしなさいということは
一般的にこのタイの世界で仏教で言うことなんです
どれぐらい時間あります？じゃあまあそこでまあ最終的にこれで話終了しますけど
あの耐えるということは世の中にごく普通にある
耐える場合は五分五分
危険もある まずその前になぜ耐えるかというと
自分が不安だから 危険がありますからなんです
危険があるんだから不安だから心配だから耐える
耐えたところで助けてくれる可能性もあるし
助けてくれない可能性もある
ですから それから耐えるになればなるほど危険度が高い
ということは結局耐えるにならないということでもあります
で 耐えるになると いつも心は揺れ動かないとはならないんです
高い建物を造って生活しようと思ったら
やっぱり固定何とか税金もそれ分高くなっちゃうんですね
維持費も高くなりますから
やっぱりもう耐えるところは高くなればなるほど心配の方も高くなってしまうと
心の揺れ動きは止まれないんだと
だったら答えは耐えないことだと
耐えないと言ったっても心弱いんだから耐えちゃうでしょうに
だったら心をしっかり強くしなくちゃいけない
という結論になるんです
心を養わなくちゃいけないんだと
だから弱みをなくせと
そうすると耐えるか耐えないかという問題はなくなってしまっちゃうんだと
そういうことでまあ最終的な結論を言ってるんですね
仏教では それで人間としてはお金に頼るんでもなくて
財産名誉に頼るんでもなくて
あなたのこと好きやと思うならばいいことをしておきなさいよと
というぐらいのことなんです
だから我々はもうちょっと言いたいこといっぱいありましたけど
人間として一番幸せなのは
私は何も悪いことをしてないんだと
よく良い人生やってきたんだと
人を助けましたし 友達も助けましたと
やらなくちゃいかんことを全部やりましたと
親に尽くしましたと 旦那に夫に尽くしましたと
奥さんに尽くしましたと
子供のことをよく見ましたと
借金もないんだと そうやって自分の人生を総合決算するときは
何も一言はないんだというところは
だからそうするとすごい自信がつくんです
いいことをしてやると
私は警察怖くなる必要もないし
政務省怖くなる必要もないんだと
誰にも怖くなる必要ないんだと
たとえ地獄も怖くなる必要ないんだと
私を引っ張ってみたければやってみろと
悪いことしてないんだからという堂々たる生き方ができるんですよ
まあそういうことで 我々は心をしっかりするべきですと
それこそ頼りになりますということで話を終了させていただきます
どうもありがとうございました
アーメン